we were gonna do a mini making of DOC
from lights out the short all until now
what kind of emotional highs and lows
would you put in that documentary well I
mean sort of the lows would be you know
during lights out I've got pretty
depressed there for a while when it's
like it's just that shock of oh this
isn't what I thought it was gonna be or
like I didn't think it was going to turn
out this way when you see something but
I think I mean on everything I've done
halfway through I get really depressed
that's true for the shorts even like
every short look that I've made halfway
through I want to quit because I'm like
this is this is garbage I want to
do it and then she convinces me to
actually go through with it and then
you're very happy about it later on and
that's sort of the thing that's happened
on every movie like halfway through
you're like oh this is this is bad this
is not what I wanted and but you have to
go through with it and then even on
lights out the producer told me that you
know when you see your first cut you're
gonna be you know not very happy who do
we like the first sort of assembly of it
because he was saying that you know when
Ben Affleck saw the first cut of Argo
he was like my career's over and then he
like won an Oscar and everything and
that's even though I was told that first
time I saw the cut first kind of lights
out it was like well this is I've
ruined I this up you know maybe
they can cut a cool trailer of it but
the movie is terrible but then you just
keep working out you cut out all those
little things that bother you and you
get the music in there and the DI and
everything and then at the end it's like
it's actually pretty cool so but but on
lights up for the post-production there
I was quite depressed and really thought
it was bad until we had a test screening
and I could hear the audience and feel
that energy aside okay and then that's
when it started like okay maybe this is
pretty good and that that happens on
every movie
and also after every movie wraps I also
get depressed but now after three movies
I know myself very well so I'd sort of
get through it better like when Shazam
was robbed winding down was talking to a
lot about how yeah I'm gonna get
depressed afterwards and it's gonna be
pretty hard but I know it's coming
I'm sure enough it does and then since
you've been through it so many times you
were able to write it out better because
like it's temporary even though when
you're depressed it never feels
temporary because depression sort of
yeah it tells you that everything will
be and it tells you everything has
been even the good things are bad
you know so yeah every every I think
that every movie is a roller coaster but
with highs and lows throughout but I
think just in comparing the movies I
think Annabelle creation has been the
most pleasant one because it you know
after lights out it felt like okay I
know how movies are made here I know the
whole process now how it works there's
nothing sort of unexpected and Annabelle
creation was just like it was just a
bigger budget sort of the same thing
which is like okay we have more
resources we have more days we can build
sets in a studio and it's like that was
the best experience so far even though
you still have that depression and
everything and then Shazam that was such
a step up with like a hundred million
dollar whatever a budget so it was kind
of back to lights out almost with all
these new things like visual effects and
stunts and second-unit and all these
things I haven't done before so it was
kind of it was difficult at times and
again I get depressed and then I have to
get through it and everything but you
know if I make another 100 million
dollar movie maybe it'll be like with
Annabelle creation where it's like okay
now I know how this process works and I
know what to look out for and and and
all these things but yeah do you see me
yeah I'm sorry do you think that that's
something that creators should be aware
of that no matter how proud they feel of
some
whether it's a tiny indie film or a
studio film that they will get depressed
because so much time and energy has gone
into it and oh every time I mean that's
happened to my brother as well who makes
video games like he spent seven years
making a video game and then it's done I
mean it's that thing of I don't know if
it's if we think that more is gonna
change like you work hard for like two
years like on Shazam or whatever or a
movie and like you come out of it and
like you almost think that the world is
gonna be different now where you were
gonna be different and then it's sort of
like oh it's back to the same kind of
and it's sort of a break-in routine
especially when you have like on a movie
like this you have a routine you have a
purpose you know what you're doing and
like every day you come in you see the
same people you know you eat lunch
together and you talk and you get to
know each other and then one day it's
over and it's like it's kind of like
getting fired or almost someone dying or
something it's just like oh we're sort
of back to this and it's like yeah
thinks were you don't change as much as
you expect almost cuz you're building to
this big thing and then comes out and
even if yeah it makes money and it's
it's great and people love it but it's
still that feeling of like alright well
what now or like you're kind of back to
square one in some ways which is which
is weird but it's yeah it's a part of
life I guess I guess you just have to
get to know yourself better and sort of
like yourself even more because even
though you do this big thing you're
still the same person and if you're not
comfortable with who you are you know no
big movie or big projects it's kind of
really gonna change that that's just
sort of things around it or you could
just start a new project that's the
thing I mean right now it's like oh I
have to get started on something new and
[Music]
you